thank you Andy mm-hmm this isn't just a
pretty picture this is the amount of
water vapor in the atmosphere on the day
Hurricane Katrina made landfall we've
been able to monitor the amount of
atmospheric moisture from space since
1988 and that record shows an increase
in water vapor about the 7% increase we
expect for a degree Celsius warming of
the lower atmosphere and I'll get back
to this later we look at measurements
from space of water vapor and
temperature to try and do this
separation of human and natural effects
on climate that Andy mentioned so 23
years ago my life changed dramatically I
was asked to be a convening lead author
for chapter 8 of the second assessment
report of the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change or IPCC they were set up
by the World Meteorological Organization
and the United Nations Environment
Program to advise the nations of the
world what we know about the physical
science of the climate system what we
know about likely impacts of climate
change on stuff we care about water
resources energy agriculture human
health and also to consider possible
mitigation and adaptation strategies I
was in charge of chapter 8 of the
physical science report that chapter
dealt with detection of climate change
and attribution of causes and after one
and a half years of work involving
dozens of scientists around the world
this was our bottom line finding 12
words the balance of evidence suggests a
discernible human influence on global
climate it was at least in my opinion
the first time that the international
scientific community had spoken with one
voice and said we've looked at the
evidence humans are no longer innocent
bystanders in the climate system they
are actively changing Earth's climate
nothing prepared me for the reaction to
those twelve words I was investigating
by Congress my sources of funding were
studied by Dana Rohrabacher now no
longer in Congress there were calls for
my dismissal with dishonor from my
position at Lawrence Livermore National
Lab it was rumored that I was about to
be indicted by The Hague International
Court of Justice for quote falsification
of international scientific documents
unquote as a scientist you're prepared
to stand up in front of your peers and
defend your findings the appropriateness
of your research methods but not your
integrity your decency your honesty so
it was a bit of a shock but of course
science moves on and in 2013 the fifth
assessment report of the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change was published that's the most
recent report it came to a much more
definitive finding regarding the reality
of human effects on climate contrasts
those two statements cautious balance of
evidence suggests no real attempt to
quantify the size of the human effect on
climate - it is extremely likely that
human influence has been the dominant
cause of the observed warming since the
mid 20th century were extremely likely
had a specific meaning in IPCC speak
greater than 95% probability that the
statement was correct and the other big
difference between the balance of
evidence finding and the more recent
statement is the latter is saying we see
signs fingerprints of human effects on
climate everywhere in sea level and ice
and snow in circulation patterns so how
did we get from A to B how did we get
from the balance of evidence to this
much more definitive finding that's
partly what I'm going to talk to you
about today so here's what I'm going to
cover lines of evidence what is the
evidence that climate scientists study
in order to separate human and natural
effects on climate what is pattern based
fingerprinting
how do we apply traditional pattern
recognition methods to try and separate
human caused changes in the climate
system from the rich month the month
year to year and decade to decade
natural variability of the climate
system I think it's important to give
some sense of history who were the key
figures in this field what do they do
then I'm going to give you an example
from our own work at Livermore with
satellite based measurements of the
temperature of the lower atmosphere the
troposphere finally some conclusions and
then I'm going to be 64 in a couple of
weeks I've taken a trip down memory lane
and tried to reflect on what did I
actually learn from my experiences 23
years ago with the IPCC and I'll briefly
share some of those lessons learned so
the bottom line is there are multiple
lines of evidence that enable us to
discriminate between human and natural
effects on climate what is what you
might call basic physics we know a lot
about the heat trapping properties of
greenhouse gases and have known hmm
since the work of Tyndall over a century
ago then there's what you might call
circumstantial evidence from hmm
understanding of the heat trapping
properties of greenhouse gases certain
things follow if we burn fossil fuels
increased co2 the ocean should warm we
should be able to see changes in sea
level we should see changes in the
extent of snow sea ice so you can look
for those things and you can see whether
there's some qualitative agreement
between your physical understanding of
how the climate system should respond
and observations of change in the
climate system then there's what you
might call deep time so folks here at
Stanford and around the world look at
indirect recorders of temperature and
precipitation change what are those
things
tree rings ice cores pollen records
things whose abundance or whose physical
properties ring width ring density
depend on changes in the climate in some
complex way so by looking at ice cores
for example as I'll show you later we
can now go back in Antarctica nearly a
million years and reconstruct nearly a
million years of greenhouse gas changes
in the atmosphere and all of this work
tells us that what is going on since the
Industrial Revolution is unusual
relative to deep time
then there's fingerprinting and the
premise and fingerprinting is that
patterns have value patterns tell you
things about the causes of climate
change so what is fingerprinting as Andy
said and we didn't agree on this at all
climate change is a combination of
things that are acting simultaneously so
there are natural changes in the sun's
energy output on a range of timescales
11 years longer we've measured the sun's
energy output from space using
spaceborne radiometers since 1979
further back in time we look at sunspots
and make inferences about long time
scale changes in the sun's energy output
we look at things like 10 beryllium
so-called cosmogenic isotopes whose
abundance is dependent on changes in the
sun over time and this is purely natural
in addition there are changes in
volcanic activity this is satellite
imagery of Mount Pinatubo in the
Philippines which erupted catastrophic
ly in June 1991 a big volcano like
Pinatubo admits a lot of sulfur dioxide
when that sulfur dioxide reaches the
upper atmosphere the stratosphere it can
form liquid phase sulfuric acid droplets
those little droplets reflect some of
the incoming sunlight back to space
prevent it from penetrating deeper into
the atmosphere and cool the lower
atmosphere and
service sometimes for years mmm and if
you have succession of volcanoes you can
have a long-term effect on the ocean
purely natural in addition to changes in
the Sun and volcanoes there are internal
oscillations of the climate system
things that we know about here in
California like El Ninos and la niñas
these have nothing to do with changes in
the Sun or volcanoes they're purely
internal oscillatory modes of the
climate system natural modes we call
them think of a belt if you have a bell
and you ring it it rings in a certain
way depending on the shape of the bell
the composition of the material the
climate system likes to ring in certain
ways and one way is El Nino and La Nina
so they have a typical time scale of 3
to 5 years they have a typical spatial
pattern El Ninos involve this warming in
the Eastern equatorial Pacific that you
can see there la Nina's are sort of the
inverse of El Ninos and there is a whole
zoo of these natural modes of
variability operating on different space
and different time scales Atlantic
multidecadal oscillation things like the
shorter term Maddon julen Julian
oscillation so you're a climate
scientist that's what you do you study
these natural modes in the climate
system you try and understand their
statistical properties and the physics
that drives them but again that's
internal variability it's not driven by
changes in the Sun or volcanoes so all
of this stuff together the Sun volcanoes
internal modes constitutes the rich
background noise against which we're
trying to identify any putative human
effect on climate so this is from Robert
Rhoda at UC Berkeley it shows 10,000
years in Antarctica of trace gas
measurements of co2 measurements by
looking at bubbles trapped in ice
so people core the various locations
these are
whole bunch of different locations in
Antarctica law doum doum see Vostok
South Pole as I mentioned now going back
nearly 800,000 years you don't see
800,000 years here you've just the ten
thousand years so from zero to
present-day and going back eight
thousand years so this is a natural time
machine by extracting air trapped in
these bubbles and then cleverly
monitoring levels of co2 and other trace
gases you can do this reconstruction
that you see here and what's apparent is
how unusual the the present day is in
the context of the past as has been
widely reported in the last week or two
at mon aloha observatory we've now
crossed 415 parts per million a level of
co2 in the atmosphere that we likely
have not seen for three million years on
ice age timescales levels of atmospheric
co2 typically fluctuate between about
180 and 280 parts per million so we're
very far beyond what we've experienced
in recent geological history in terms of
atmospheric co2 levels and by looking at
isotopes of carbon lighter and heavier
isotopes we know that most of that
increase in atmospheric co2 is due to
human caused fossil fuel burning so
burning fossil fuels has a specific
isotopic signature scientists at
Livermore in many other places around
the world look at that
isotopic signature that's how we know
beyond a shadow of a doubt that roughly
80 percent of that increase in
atmospheric co2 from pre-industrial to
present day is fossil fuel burning in
addition to changes in greenhouse gases
like co2
there's particulate pollution this is
satellite imagery of the Himalayas at a
certain time of year when there was a
lot of
hmmm slash-and-burn agriculture a lot of
industrial pollution this haze that you
see there is in terms of its optical
depth equivalent to a major volcanic
eruption so again when we produce air
assault suit aerosols sulfate aerosols
these things in areas where there are
heavy atmospheric burdens can in the
case of sued aerosols darker aerosols
absorb incoming sunlight and heat in
situ other aerosols are more reflective
these these particulates can have
profound effects locally and even
regionally so again if you're a climate
scientist that's what you do you try and
understand these aerosols and also how
they interact with clouds how they might
change cloud brightness or change cloud
lifetime aerosols are a topic that is
receiving and has received intense
attention in the climate science
community both from an observational
viewpoint and from a modeling viewpoint
for years now humans have modified the
surface of the land so this is satellite
imagery of logging roads in rondônia in
the Brazilian rainforest when you
transform the surface of the land in
such a massive systematic way you change
fluxes of moisture from the soil into
the atmosphere
you change the albedo the reflectivity
of the surface and again like aerosols
locally and probably even regionally
where we've made these major
transformations of the land surface you
have the capability of affecting climate
so all of this is not natural and the
challenge is that the natural and the
non natural changes are happening
simultaneously think of a symphony so
when you listen to us you know you're in
the audience there and sound is coming
from the strings and percussion and
different sections and you're trying to
isolate these individual contributions
to the overall music that you hear well
same of the climate system all this
stuff is going on simultaneously and the
challenge is reliable quantification of
the individual contributions of the
things that I've shown you sorry well
it's interesting that you say that
another thing that's been widely
reported in the last couple of weeks is
efforts by a first-rate musician to
transform data into music and to use I
believe global mean temperature data and
generate some code for Earth or dirge
for Earth so people have tried indeed to
interprets climate data in terms of
images in terms of sound yeah not a good
not a good song so what is
fingerprinting yes yes
as we have turned we basically many
areas TT water service waterfront area
again insignificant locally and
regionally so one of my colleagues at
Livermore Selene Ball feed looks at the
impact of irrigation actually with a guy
here at Stanford now David LaBelle they
tried to understand the implications of
large-scale irrigation in the Central
Valley of California and it turns out
that in the Central Valley that's a non
negligible effect you have a quasi
permanent source of moisture there that
you didn't have before so you can use
model simulations you can use
observations to try and understand the
impact of that change and again locally
that can be significant in terms of
things like the diurnal temperature
range changes between no worries I'm
used to having local signal-to-noise
problems yeah so look locally these kind
of things can matter I would classify
that again as land surface modification
and mmm you know when you do those kind
of things I didn't mention for the
logging stuff there you also affect
surface roughness in fact all kinds of
things in complex ways and of course a
big concern has been large-scale
deforestation in Indonesia and in the
Amazon and lots of folks have tried to
understand not only the impact of that
in terms of albedo and moisture fluxes
but also in terms of carbon storage
anyway let's get on to fingerprinting
now so the basic strategy is the things
I introduced to you the Sun and
volcanoes natural internal variability
human influence that each one of those
has a characteristic fingerprint
hmm and none of them do exactly the same
thing when you begin to look in multiple
dimensions when you begin to look at
geographical patterns or you look at
slices through the atmosphere from the
surface right up to the stratosphere or
you look at slices through the ocean and
for a long time climate scientists
didn't exploit that space-time
information they just looked at one
number the average temperature of
Earth's surface global mean temperature
but it turns out that the global mean
isn't very useful in discriminating
between multiple factors there so why
not look at patterns hmm and basically
we use statistical methods to try and
quantify the patterns similarity either
in terms of geographical maps or again
altitude '''l slices through the
atmosphere be taught between some
computer model predicted fingerprint of
human influence and satellite
observations or in situ data and then
you try and look at whether that
agreement that you see between the
search for human influence fingerprint
and observations is truly significant or
whether the vagaries of natural internal
climate variability perhaps combined
with the Sun and volcanic activity could
have given you that kind of fingerprint
match so that's the challenge and we'll
get back to that in a minute but yes yes
sir
testing flies a merging power no so what
I do has nothing to do with the kind of
forensics that other folks at Lawrence
Livermore National Lab are involved with
they do that kind of forensics my my
beat is the climate system although
there is some intersection between those
two worlds and Atmospheric nuclear
testing in the 50s generated things like
bomb tritium that climate scientists
uses tracers to look at the penetration
of that tritium into the ocean and that
gives them the ability to try and look
at the performance of the the ocean
component of these climate models and
whether there's some consistency between
the pathways and the speed by which
tritium got into the real-world ocean
and tritium gets into the model ocean
yes sir you had a question
I don't know that I can answer that
question I think fingerprinting has been
influential but as I pointed out at the
at the outset our confidence in the
reality of human effects on climate
comes from many different things not
just fingerprinting there is this
physical understanding from the lab of
greenhouse gases and how they trap heat
from other planets and knowing
relationships between co2 levels or
greenhouse gas levels and temperature on
other planets think Venus there is this
deep time information that I pointed out
from ice cores tree rings that has been
very powerful and clearly shows how
unusual the last hundred and fifty years
have been in the context of deep time
[Music]
perhaps my personal prejudice
since I'm involved with fingerprinting
is that it has been powerful and I'll
try and show you why I want to give a
toy example now of the power of
fingerprinting so here's this maligned
global mean temperature that I talked
about so the average temperature of the
Earth's surface over land and the
average temperature of ocean surfaces
this particular estimate is from the
Goddard Institute for Space Studies in
New York they're about four groups
around the world that do this if I had
showed you results from other groups
they would be quite similar to this our
estimate is from these four groups
global mean temperature that the average
global mean temperature of your surface
has increased by about one point two
degrees Celsius so nearly two degrees
Fahrenheit since 1880 and there's been a
lot of complexity in that increase and
again if you're a climate scientists you
try and
study not just the overall trend but the
Wiggles and identify the effects of
volcanic eruptions the cooling they
caused big El Ninos big la niñas the
reason I'm showing this is I guarantee
you can go to the editorial pages of
your local newspaper even now and
someone will say all of this surface
warming is due to an uptick in the sun's
energy output so that's a testable
hypothesis what is the consequence of
that kind of hypothesis what is the
consequence of positing a more active
Sun from 1880 to present obviously this
is not drawn to scale this is my simple
Simpsons view of the Sun and the earth
so if these folks were right and all of
that warming I just showed you were due
to an uptick in the sun's energy output
you would expect to see heating
throughout the full vertical extent of
the atmosphere that would be the
fingerprint if you will of a very active
Sun and we can do computer model
experiments where we change only one
thing on Stein was very fond of Gedanken
experiment thought experiments
experiments that you couldn't do in the
real world in the computer model world
you can change just one thing at a time
and that's what's being done here this
is from simulations performed by our
colleagues at the National Center for
Atmospheric Research in Boulder in
Colorado what you're seeing here is a
slice through the Earth's atmosphere
plump close to the surface right up to
the stratosphere to about 20 miles and
from the North Pole to the South Pole in
this particular model it was run with
our best estimate of changes in the
sun's energy output something we call
total solar irradiance from 1958 through
to the end of the 20th century yellow
colors indicate yellow to red indicates
warming here so indeed as in my simple
toy example in this particular model
for the estimated relatively weak
increase in the sun's energy output in
the second half of the 20th century
you'd expect to see something like this
weak heating throughout the full extent
of the atmosphere so this fingerprint is
fundamentally different
this shows warming of the lower
atmosphere the troposphere and cooling
of the upper atmosphere the stratosphere
this is from the same model but in this
simulation human-caused changes in
greenhouse gases so carbon dioxide
methane nitrous oxide
chlorofluorocarbons were changed
according to our best understanding of
how these gases actually changed in the
atmosphere over the second half of the
20th century fundamentally different and
we'll get back to that later because the
first guy who looked at this kind of
curious dipole structure warming low
down cooling up high was Suki Minami at
the geophysical fluid dynamics lab in
Princeton in a paper published in 1967
before we had satellite data before we
really had sophisticated climate models
so as I'll show you later that early
prediction hmm was very consistent with
these full climate model results shown
in the bottom panel here that when we
burn more fossil fuels and increased
levels of atmospheric co2 we more
effectively trap heat lower in the
atmosphere unless heat escapes higher up
in the atmosphere it's not like dialing
up or dialing down the Sun where you're
changing the total amount of energy
incident at the top of the atmosphere
we're redistributing heat in the
atmosphere so you might ask okay what do
observations look like and we're lucky
in California we have in Santa Rosa a
company a private company called remote
sensing systems led by Frank Wentz and
Karl Mears probably the premier
organization in the world for satellite
microwave radiometry what I'm going to
show you now are their results
these are from about 15 polar orbiting
satellites primarily from the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
and this record started in late 1978 and
goes through to the present I'm showing
you the full 40 year satellite record
here again a slice through the
atmosphere from the South Pole to the
North Pole and from 2 kilometers right
up to 20 kilometers so the bottom line
here is that this pattern of warming in
the lower atmosphere and cooling in the
upper atmosphere is fundamentally
inconsistent with the Sun explains
everything
fingerprint yeah really good question so
the question was why is there so much
difference between the two poles in the
lower atmosphere it's because of
amplifying feedback mechanisms so over
the Arctic we've seen as we've ramped up
greenhouse gases these amplifying
feedbacks associated with the behavior
of snow and ice so snow and ice are
bright reflective surfaces when you
increase co2 by burning fossil fuels and
start warming up the Arctic you melt
back snow and Arctic sea ice and you
expose darker underlying ocean and land
surfaces for instance we know from
satellite measurements of Arctic sea ice
extent that in September the minimum
extent of Arctic sea ice in the northern
hemisphere the extent has decreased by
40 percent over the 40 years satellite
record so what's happening then as
you're changing the albedo by melting
back snow and ice more incoming sunlight
is being absorbed at the surface by
underlying darker less reflective
surfaces you melt back more ice that's
an amplifying positive feedback effect
now why is why is Antarctica different
much of Antarctica is over 3,000 meters
so it's a high continent and
continuously or pretty much continuously
covered by snow and by ice so that's why
there's this profound difference between
the the two the two poles they're in
terms of the degree of warming where
that's one of the reasons why another
reason why is related to the asymmetry
you see in the upper atmosphere so
there's more cooling in the upper
atmosphere over Antarctica than there is
over the North Pole and that's due to
the Antarctic ozone hole
hmm so ozone is also a greenhouse gas
its concentration changes as a function
of height there's a there's a maximum
higher up in the atmosphere in the lower
stratosphere by producing
chlorofluorocarbons we've catalyzed the
destruction of lower stratospheric ozone
and that means that the lower
stratosphere absorbs less heat because
there's less ozone than it previously
did and that effect is a maximum over
Antarctica in part because it's also
temperature dependent and the
temperatures are coldest in in the
stratosphere over Antarctica so some of
that human-caused lower stratospheric
cooling associated with the Antarctic
ozone hole propagates down into the
troposphere and that's another reason
why there's some asymmetry there between
the northern hemisphere in the southern
hemisphere anyway you know the bottom
line is is this there's the Sun only
fingerprint the observations the
satellite observations look nothing like
that is there other evidence I mentioned
a little earlier these satellite based
measurements of the sun's energy output
total solar irradiance that's what you
see on the bottom panel these are from a
variety of different spaceborne
radiometers you nicely see this 11-year
sunspot cycle more sunspots more solar
energy output
your sunspots less solar energy output
but the kicker is that over the period
we directly monitored the Sun from space
global mean temperature has increased
but there's been no net increase in
solar irradiance so it's another
fundamental difficulty you face if
you're a solar enthusiast and are
arguing that all of the surface warming
is due to the Sun well there's been no
measured increase in the sun's energy
output and the lower stratosphere has
cooled so that's the power of looking at
patterns here okay who were some of the
principles this guy who looks a little
bit like Kenny Rogers is the former
director of the Max Planck Institute for
meteorology in Hamburg I did my postdoc
with him at the Max Planck Institute in
Hamburg and I remember one famous trip
where we were flying to Denver and one
of the flight attendants actually
thought he was Kenny Rogers and we got
bumped up to business class so that was
kind of cool sorry I did too yeah so I
was part of his entourage so hustlin is
a very very interesting gentleman he
spent most of his scientific career
working on grand unification theory and
probably devoted only a small fraction
of his brain to climate science but that
small fraction led to some pretty
remarkable breakthroughs in climate
science and one of them was in a paper
that he wrote in 1979 in an obscure
conference proceedings where he said we
are going to continue to burn fossil
fuels the plant is going to warm here's
how you look for this signal electrical
engineers know how to do this they
constantly look for coherent signals
embedded in noisy data and
he put a figure like this in his papers
so he said imagine we have two principal
directions where we know something about
the the pattern of natural variations
say in surface temperature in two
directions two principal directions and
we also know something in those two
directions about how the system is going
to respond to human caused changes some
greenhouse gases but let's say the the
yellow ellipse in those two directions
is the climate noise face and Hassim ins
hmm suggestion in this paper was you
don't look in the direction where the
signal the human-caused warming signal
is largest in that two space instead you
want to maximize signal-to-noise you
want to look in a direction where the
signal is smaller but it's larger
relative to the noise so in the kind of
work that I do that involves a pattern
rotation and the kind of work other
people do it can involve a rotation both
in in spatial patterns as well as in
frequencies where you you look for a
signal in a direction where you have
knowledge about the pattern of natural
variability you have knowledge about the
timescales of natural variability and
you know that the signal is large
relative to the noise that was a key
insight that was 1979 his paper was
couched in tensor notation so few people
in in climate science could understand
it when I got to Hamburg in 1987 my job
was to try and understand what he had
published in 1979 and put it into
practice in the real world so to do this
kind of signal detection with real world
data at the same time that hustling was
looking at fingerprinting at the Mocs
Punk Institute Jerry North at Texas A&M
University was independently working on
very similar things and one of Jerry's
big insights was don't just look at the
patterns so I showed you a nice example
of
this before if one wanted to
discriminate between some coherent
human-caused warming signal in the top
panel and the much noisier patterns of
natural climate variability Gerry's
insight was don't just look at the
patterns you have this time scale
information - like the 11-year time
scale of the sun's energy output utilize
both the time information and the space
information do this stuff in the
frequency domain so that was a key
insight as well I've already mentioned
this guy for peso tsuki Manavi
one of the most eminent climate
scientists in our field
one of the first climate modelers in
1967 with dick weather old he published
this paper in the journal of atmospheric
sciences and you probably can't see it
so let me explain what's going on here
this again is a slice through the
atmosphere but this is global mean this
doesn't show you things as a function of
latitude this is global mean temperature
from close to the surface at the bottom
a hundred hectopascals right up to the
stratosphere and in a very simple
climate model
Manavi and weather rolled increased
atmospheric co2 in increments from 150
parts per million that's the dashed line
to 300 parts per million to 600 parts
per million and what they found is
exactly what I showed you that the
stratosphere cooled the upper atmosphere
cooled and the troposphere warmed so
this is now regarded as one of the most
famous papers and climate science and
their bottom line finding was this the
larger the mixing ratio of carbon
dioxide the warmer is the equilibrium
temperature of the Earth's surface and
troposphere the larger the mixing ratio
of carbon dioxide the colder is the
equilibrium temperature of the
stratosphere and one of the reasons I
mentioned this is a knock on climate
models is they're not falsifiable
they don't make predictions that can
actually be falsified with data not true
this was a prediction back in 1967 the
satellite year
really started in the late 1970s
so no reliable information about
stratospheric temperature we do have
some sparse weather balloons back then
in the 60s and 50s even but they don't
have the structural integrity to get up
into the stratosphere they burst above
about 20 kilometers so in a very real
sense tsuki Manabi and dick weather roll
could have been wrong but they weren't
the real world shows this warming low
down and cooling up high that they
foresaw over 50 years ago if we continue
to burn fossil fuels and ramp up
greenhouse gas levels I want to show you
not a toy example now but something that
we do together with our colleagues at
Santa Rosa they're the guys who as I
mentioned earlier are responsible for
producing microwave based estimates of
atmospheric temperature atmospheric
moisture and these these are just things
of beauty so what are these measurements
here what you see here on the left are
temperature changes in the lower
troposphere in the lower atmosphere from
santa rosa over the full 40-year
satellite record and on the right that's
an average of 37 state-of-the-art
computer models of the climate system
where human caused changes in greenhouse
gases and particulate pollution and land
surface changes have been used to drive
these models over the satellite europe
and before getting into the similarities
and differences between these patterns i
just want to explain what the satellite
measurements are they look at the
microwave emissions from oxygen
molecules and those emissions are
proportional to the temperature of broad
layers of the atmosphere by measuring a
different microwave frequencies you can
back out the temperature of different
broad layers of the atmosphere beautiful
beautiful stuff and technically
challenging because there are satellite
orbit drift effects there are instrument
calibration problems so these microwave
radio
calibrate by looking at a Hotwire target
on board and looking at cold space but
it turns out that as they're orbiting
the Earth there are times when they're
heated by the Sun and the calibration
drifts because the hot water target
drifts so a lot of complexity in
producing that kind of pattern of change
and one thing you can see there is it's
noisier than the panel on the right and
that's expected because the panel on the
right is an average over 37 different
climate models and an average in many of
those models we have multiple what we
call realizations starting from
different initial conditions so each
time you run the model you get a
different sequence of El Ninos and la
niñas of noise if you will superimposed
on the underlying signal and the noise
is quasi random in time so by averaging
over all of these things you get a much
smoother picture in the model than in
the single hand that we were dealt in
the observations the one realization
that we have but two first-order you see
some common features there so we see
what you pointed out earlier sir this
asymmetry between the Northern
Hemisphere and the southern hemisphere
in both the data and in the model we see
a larger warming over a land than over
ocean even in the troposphere even a
little remove from the direct
differences at the surface between
between the ocean and the land surface
you know they're there these differences
in specific and total heat capacity that
mean that land warms more rapidly than
ocean and you would think the higher up
you get in the atmosphere these things
are more washed out that's true but in
both you can still see this land versus
ocean imprint with larger warming over
land and over ocean so you can ask then
as as we do is there some time
increasing similarity between the
satellite patterns of troposphere
temperature change and this human
influence fingerprint so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna let this rip here I'm
going to show you individual satellite
patterns of troposphere temperature
change and I can't show you all 40s so
I'm just gonna skip over some years but
the main point to note here is that the
as you can see here the satellite data
is warming over time you know you're
getting this preferential warming
particularly at high latitudes in the
northern hemisphere you can see 2016 was
a big El Nino year so that's why we have
larger more red more warming there what
one can do then is calculate some
measure of spatial similarity between
the time varying observations and this
model projected human influence
fingerprint and you get some time series
of spatial covariance between the mm the
data and the fingerprint and I'm not
doing anything fancy here so no haslam
on rotation this is the simplest most
vanilla example the bottom line is that
there's an increasing trend which you
could see visually between the satellite
data and the search for human influence
fingerprint you can also see a lot of
structure in that so that big spike
there in 1997-1998 is a big El Nino on
average El Ninos warm the planet that's
why in 97-98 you have this increase in
spatial covariance between the
fingerprint and the data if you also
look carefully you can see that around
92 there's a big dip that's when
Pinatubo was so the cooling caused by
Pinatubo in the troposphere is the
converse of the search for fingerprint
that's why you get that decrease in in
pattern similarity so you know again the
nice thing with climate models is we can
do the counterfactual we can do this
kind of thing where you simulate a world
without human influence but with changes
in the Sun changes in volcanoes and you
can do that many times with many
different models and that gives you your
null district
you can use those kind of no human
influence simulations to look at this
this will take a little while to bring
up we have from 36 different climate
models over seven thousand two hundred
years of simulation this rich
information about patterns of natural
climate variability and again I'm not
showing you all 7200 I'm just showing
some of these things here but the bottom
line is they're not spatially coherent
they don't show warming of the entire
planet that's not the way natural
variability works yes sir
could I get back to that later
so we we have indeed looked at that
question at whether it's a model
democracy one model one vote and we
should pay equal attention to all of
these models or whether we should as we
have done regard it as a meritocracy
rather than a democracy and choose in
some letterman type sense the top ten
climate models and just do this
fingerprint analysis with the top ten
and we've done that but it turns out
that you can select the top ten in many
many different ways based on spatial
patterns based on natural variability
based on seasonal cycle based on how
well they do with average climate so we
did this kind of stuff in 70 different
ways we chose the top you know ten
models and and it turns out that for
this kind of problem it doesn't matter
whether you use the top ten or the
bottom ten models simply because as you
can see from this kind of thing here
patterns of natural variability
irrespective of which models you use are
small scale they don't show simultaneous
coherent you know coherent warming of
the entire troposphere we know of no
mode of natural climate variability that
and that can do that so again you can
use these counterfactuals world without
us to generate these patterns similarity
time series again I'm only showing 500
years and you can look at the degree of
similarity you might expect to see
between the human influence fingerprint
and random patterns of variability in
current climate models and that enables
you to do this kind of thing you can
build up a distribution of random
coherence agreement between the search
for human influence fingerprint and
patterns of natural climate variability
and then you can put on this the
satellite data so what we actually got
in the first step where we compared the
time evolving patterns of satellite
temperature change with a model human
influence fingerprint so there for all
satellite data sets there are three
groups here now from the University of
Alabama a NOAA group National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration in
Maryland and the santa rosa group for
all of the satellite data sets the
agreement that we get between the
fingerprint and the satellite data can't
be explained by natural climate
variability alone as Manifest in current
climate models so at this stage you know
someone would say well dr. santur all of
these model based estimates of natural
variability are garbage and I believe
that they systematically underestimate
the size of natural climate variability
the spurious lis inflating these results
that you're presenting here so of course
we look at those kind of things what I'm
doing here is looking at these 37
climate models the identities have been
skilfully disguised here in order to
protect the innocent and the guilty
and on the x-axis you're looking at the
variability of tropospheric temperature
and I filtered it so the x-axis is
looking at what I'll call fast
variability in tropospheric temperature
one to two year timescales the y-axis is
looking at variability on 10 to 15-year
timescales we can't really go beyond
that because we've only got 40 years of
satellite data although we have also
done this with log with longer ocean
surface temperature records so the
crosshairs are in the satellite data
okay
and I've actually centered them on
remote sensing systems what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to add model results I'm
going to populate this thing and I'm
going to call this the quadrant of doom
so what models are in the quadrant of
doom that's a bad thing particularly on
the y-axis because it's that decayed
alloys that constitutes the background
noise against which we're trying to
identify some evolving human-caused
warming signal so of all of these
state-of-the-art models are in that blue
quadrant of doom then the results I just
showed you would be spurious lis
inflated by a model under estimate of
decay ttle variability so here the first
ten models and you can see again getting
to your point sir that there's quite a
range of model performance in terms of
the amplitude of year-to-year
variability for tropospheric temperature
you can see though this is all 37 of
them now that the model average is
actually higher on both the fast time
scales and the slow time scales than the
satellite data so while some models are
in the quadrant of doom on average model
estimates of decadal time scale
variability exceed those we have from
satellite data now there are many
uncertainties associated with this kind
of comparison this is a time domain
approach we've done it comprehensively
in the in the frequency domain as well
where
you know the challenge is to isolate
internal variability and you can try a
whole bunch of different ways of
removing and externally forced the
human-caused signal and looking at the
residuals fitting statistical models to
those residuals and you know again you
do that because you only have one
realization of the observation so if you
want to make model data comparisons you
need to up your sample size in order to
make reliable statistical inferences and
the bottom line from all of this work is
there's there's no evidence that on
average these models are in the quadrant
of doom and again we've done this with
independent and longer ocean surface
temperature records same thing so I
think our results are conservative
rather than liberal yes sir yeah we can
we can do that and have done that for
surface temperature so arguably surface
temperature records reliable records go
back to about 1880 so we now have four
surface temperature roughly a hundred
and thirty years or so one of the
problems with surface temperature unlike
these satellite measurements is the
coverage degrades the further back you
go in time so the error bars on the
surface measurements get larger and the
coverage changes are spatially
non-random so as you go back further in
time then we're sampling shipping routes
than the North Atlantic some
trans-pacific trading routes but very
little in the southern ocean and very
little in the Arctic so that's a
fundamental problem with looking at
surface temperature but to first order
when we do look at longer surface
temperature records we get the same
result that I just showed you that
there's no evidence that on average
models decay --dl timescales surface
temperature variable
is in the quadrant of doom it's actually
outside another thing we can do and you
might wonder about is is when when could
we actually identify with high
statistical confidence a human-caused
fingerprint in the data and that's what
you're that's what you're seeing here
this is from a paper we've been working
on for a while the the rage and climate
science are are these things called lice
large initial condition ensembles every
modelling group has lice so the idea
there is that again in the real world we
only have one draw one specific sequence
of natural climate variability and the
response to forcing but in model world
you can go back say to 1950 or 1920
which was what was done here with this
particular climate model developed at
the National Center for Atmospheric
Research and you can perturb the initial
conditions and you can run the same
model 40 times which was what was done
here the same physical climate model
with the same greenhouse gas increases
over the 20th century but each time you
get a different random sequence of noise
superimposed on the underlying signal so
it's sort of like many worlds you know
each each one of these 40 trajectories
is some plausible internally consistent
climate trajectory in this particular
model and that's how I generated this
box plot here this is for tropospheric
temperature and the crosses are when I
search for the human influence
fingerprint that I just showed you in
these three different satellite data
sets from remote sistent sensing systems
university of alabama and maryland and
you can ask is the fingerprint detection
in the real world those
crosses within the range of stochastic
uncertainty and fingerprint detection
time that I infer from these large
initial condition ensembles and in most
cases it is so that's interesting and
that's encouraging in a sense that we
can now although these ensembles are
very computationally expensive we can
run the real world many times and then
ask whether some property of real world
climate change we care about is within
that stochastic uncertainty and again
here for tropospheric temperature it is
conclusions I've only shown you one
thing your tropospheric temperature but
we and others around the world using
independent methods using different data
sets have looked at many many different
things we've looked at surface
temperature atmospheric temperature
atmospheric circulation patterns
rainfall the amount of water vapour in
the atmosphere which is what I showed
you on the first slide many many
different things snow ice and in each
case the observed changes that we
measured and monitored from space from
the ground can't be explained by natural
causes alone so to me the thing that's
so compelling about this is that
internal and physical consistency of
different measurements of results from
different groups we've kicked the tires
we can't find any natural cause that can
explain what we've seen and many folks
around the world have have told the
story so what did I learn in this 23 24
year Odyssey one lesson learned was
defend scientific understanding so
imagine you wake up one morning and
someone who is very powerful the
President of the United States says
publicly that everything you have done
is a hoax and a conspiracy hmm you have
a choice to make either you retreat your
office and close the door and hope that
things will
eventually resolved or you defend that
hard-won technical understanding hmm and
I had to do that back in 1995 after the
balance of evidence finding I had no
choice
like it or not I was a representative of
an entire community and I had to explain
what the IPCC process was what the
evidence was and how we had arrived at
the discernible human influence finding
so defend technical understanding never
engage in science by eminence of
position another profound lesson learned
when you're confronted by justifiable
criticism don't say trust me I'm a
scientist at a National Lab do the
research required to address the
criticism to see whether it has merit or
not and I'm proud of the fact that
that's what we've done
we haven't discounted solar only
hypotheses and said that's rubbish we've
looked at whether those hypotheses fit
the bill and we've looked at many other
alternate non human influence hypotheses
about the causes of climate change to me
that's critically important do due
diligence don't just preach to the choir
i'm funded by the US Department of
Energy and to me that conveys some
responsibility I have to be accountable
in the public arena I have to tell
people even people who are skeptical
about me and everything I do what we did
with the money we received what we
learned and why it matters to them and I
have to answer questions finally declare
your values so I'm going to declare my
values here I'm not just a climate
scientist I'm a climber and I've climbed
in the Alps in the Himalayas in the
North Cascades most recently in Alaska
for over 45 years now over one human
lifetime I've seen profound changes in
these beautiful fragile high alpine
places these are all pictures that I've
taken during the course of my climbing
career to me hmm in addition to the
scientific imperative to understand the
nature and causes of climate change and
likely outcomes if we do nothing about
this problem there's also some larger
discussion we need to have about values
what do these places mean what does it
mean to lose the wild to lose the Great
Barrier Reef to lose the Juneau Icefield
how are we diminished what does it mean
for future generations
if they can't experience these places in
the way that we did so it's not just
about science it's also about values and
it's about risk this is from last summer
this is at camp 18 in the Juneau
Icefield I've been going to the June
since 2012 I believe the Juneau Icefield
Research Program has been a in existence
since the late 1940s it's the second
longest record of glacial mass balance
around the world and when you stand
there and look down onto the beauty and
immensity of the Gilkey trench as this
is called this confluence of streams of
ice it's not just academic so the work
that's done out there is to chronicle
changes in mass balance using a variety
of different techniques like
ground-penetrating radar so essentially
do tomography of ice sheets to look at
the position of soot and particulates on
the surface of the ice and how that
accelerates melting it's it's just an
amazing place and since 2001 the surface
height of the Gilkey glacier at this
location has decreased by about 150 feet
a paper appeared in in nature just a
couple of weeks ago that looks at
changes in glaciers around the world
using satellite remote sensing in situ
measurements Alaska it turned out of all
the regions they looked at is one of the
fastest melting glacial areas in the
planet go see these things now while you
can and let's have that discussion about
values
just finally again taking that trip down
memory lane
the real awards and rewards over a
scientific career are the fellow
travelers and I've had many I've been
privileged to work with brilliant women
and men around the world and this work
could not have been done without their
generous contributions
I believe in building scientific
coalition's of the Willing where you're
working together with microwave
specialists satellite remote sensing
folks climate modelers Bayesian
statisticians and the joy has been
learning from my colleagues at Livermore
and around the world
thank you very much I'd be happy to
answer any questions you might have